we've all heard the saying food is love
but for latrice mcarthur
it holds especially true she's a chef
and a teacher and the founder of
wellness with bella an after-school
program focused on healthy eating and
meals for those in need please
welcome latrice
hello
hi nice to meet you oh my gosh you look
so beautiful
you look great as usual oh thank you
this is a ton of hair makeup and
wardrobe trust me
and i was curious what inspired you
to jump into community action and start
your program
so a little over 10 years ago when the
former first lady michelle obama started
her
let's move initiative she asked for
chefs to come in and volunteer
in elementary schools and i was working
as a private chef at the time
and decided sure i can go in and
anticipated volunteering
um maybe a day or two possibly a week
but after spending time with the kids
i saw a tremendous need to be able to
educate them on food and nutrition and
culinary skills as well
and within a year of the nonprofit was
started
and you discovered during the pandemic
like a new sense of purpose will you
tell us about that
absolutely so initially uh we got the
call that schools were going to be
closed just like everyone else we
anticipated that it would only be
for two weeks and we said sure we can
figure that out and
get out a couple of hundred meals and so
i pulled together our volunteers and we
figured out how to
deliver and that couple of hundred meals
that we anticipated has turned into now
15 000 meals that we have been able to
deliver
i mean latrice you are the angel
that we all hope exists on the planet
because when we all
watched what happened at the beginning
of school closures
it was so heartbreaking so scary and
even on your website the mission
statement says change a life today
and that's so simple and so impactful
and that's exactly what you're doing but
over and over and over again
you know and it seems so simplistic it
doesn't seem like it should be an issue
but hunger is a huge issue
and you know we can't expect our
children to go to school and be able to
function and thrive
if they have not had a proper meal and
so this is my
mission to make sure that not only are
we providing the meals for our students
but also
making sure that they are ready to
thrive in school
to be able to close some of those
success and education gaps that
make this in these communities well
thank goodness for you latrice
and um i heard that you're a big admirer
of ann burrell is that true
that is not true i love her by the way
obsessed i i love her i love her style i
love her the way she
her recipes the way she brought from the
kitchen i i really adore her
oh well that's good because she adores
you too guess who's here it's amber all
[Music]
[Applause]
how cute are you and that smile is just
infectious oh and hi drew
hi anne when i heard about you lid trees
and all of the wonderful stuff that you
do
for so many people it actually makes me
weepy
um i'm a huge fan of chicago and i go
there kind of regularly so i feel like
the next time i'm in town i'm gonna like
swing by and maybe i'll help you cook
for a day or something
and i would love that
not again to be a weirdo but i want in
on that
okay and um we at the show wanted to
um donate to your mission um and to the
families in chicago so our friends at
trifecta
and organic meal delivery service are
i'm giving you
500 meals to distribute throughout your
community
um and we thank them so
much
[Applause]
it's not enough but it's a start and and
um did you
want to add anything to that well
literacy is everything that you do is so
important so the people at trifecta want
to give you 500 more meals
so that's one thousand meals
oh my god i mean
all the work that you do is so important
and
we just want to keep that smile as
bright and as
as electric as it absolutely is
absolutely thank you guys so much oh
this is amazing our kids are going to
love this
thank you thank you to trifecta for
helping us
do this and anne barrell i love you so
much
i can't believe i'm getting to do this
with you i see you very much i love you
latrice i mean you are just a rock star
and thank you guys so much for including
me in this
ah yes thank you both so much this is so
exciting thank you
oh and anne oh be sure to check out the
new season of worst cooks in america
premiering april 25th
at 9 00 p.m 8 p.m central on the food
[Music]
network
you